a escala en parís ayuda palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
en estos momentos se está celebrando el
tour de francia' estamos muy pendientes
de la prestación de los colombianos y de
si llegan bernal revalidará o no su
título y hoy hace escala en parís una de
las personas que mejor conoce el
ciclismo el periodista francés
jose bienvenido y muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros
buenos días usted ha trabajado 33 años
en el diario deportivo l'equipe ha
cubierto 19 tours de francia 15 vueltas
a españa vueltas a colombia clásicos rcn
mundiales y recientemente acaba de
publicar el libro bernal l fish de la
cordillera
bernal y los hijos de la cordillera en
la editorial solar en seguida hablamos
de este libro pero antes yo le quería
preguntar cómo ve usted la edición de
este año del tour es un tanto particular
es un tubo muy montañoso mucha montaña
28 puestos 4 ligadas en alto una
cronoescalada y sobre todo una tercera
semana jugosa en los alpes es una
barbaridad
entonces
es un tour dibujado por los escaladores
y justamente vamos a ver de los
escaladores de los colombianos el joven
el invernal se convirtió el año pasado
en el primer colombiano en ganar el tour
qué opciones tiene de revalidar ese
título y qué opciones hay para otros
colombianos como por ejemplo en la hero
quintana del que se habló mucho en
pasadas ediciones
pero ella no es el mismo que el que ganó
el tour en 2019 él dicen que tiene un
problema de espalda
y por ahora está un poquito un escalón
por debajo de primor solís que es el
máximo favorito y el vencedor en el
cierre esloveno el esloveno sí y también
el otro el jovencito solo que no
tendréis por azar
y invernal está evidentemente un tono
por debajo pero con los durísimos de la
tercera semana y su tremenda facultades
de cooperación
podría dar según mi opinión podría dar
la vuelta a la tortilla y hay opciones
para otros colombianos sí
diego terminó cuarto y no he a la
primera llegada en alto y ha dado ese
día garantía sobre el estado de su
rodilla que estaba adicionado
también vivo
va a escondido pero cada día un poquito
mejor
esteban chaves quedan en el lote de los
favoritos si se quita de encima la mala
suerte superman lópez puede llegar
alguna etapa igual que dani martínez
pero mi apuesta en ese tour se llama se
agita para mí lo veo mejor joven en mayo
brown en la llegada en país vamos a
hablar de este apasionante libro que
empieza hablando de the gun bernal
y que ha publicado recientemente bernal
y los hijos de la cordillera es
apasionante y muy emotivo porque cuenta
la historia del ciclismo colombiano y de
sus protagonistas una historia que nos
lleva hasta los inicios de la pasión
colombiana por por el ciclismo con la
primera edición del tour de colombia la
vuelta a colombia en 1951 y su ganador
efraín el zipa forero porque colombia ha
producido y exportado
tantos ciclistas y otros países que
también tienen montaña los andes no lo
han hecho bueno yo te puedo hablar de
colombia colombia en colombia hay más de
20 millones de vice es el medio de
transporte más usado y el ciclismo de
toda la vida de toda la vida pero no ha
sido el deporte rey
para muchos la única manera de escapar
de una vida sin futuro cosechas patatas
o cebollas en el campo de sol a sol o de
las vacas
o apuntar en las fábricas el salva vida
el único salvaría es a la bici entonces
en eso pues con eso con esa pasión creo
que todos un día han intentado poner un
dorsal y medir si sus fuerzas en la
colonia en la mayoría de las historias
justamente explica ese pasado de
infancia humilde familias pobres muchos
trabajan desde desde niños comienzan en
carreras locales con bicicletas muy
pesadas panaderas se les llama son
historias de superación
con qué historia se queda qué historia
le impactó más cuando estuvo en colombia
hablando con los ciclistas la historia
que más me impactó fue la de mauricio
soler
él
mejor escalador del tubo 2017 mauricio
hasta su fama en el tour x 2011 donde
pudo perder la vida era un campeón
grandísimo campeón en la bici favorito
del tubo 2011
pero se salvó después de un mes de coma
y de 22 fracturas
con algunas que nunca podrán sanar y con
una y que con una tremenda y una
descomunal fuerza mental llegó con una
rehabilitación donde le tocó a aprender
caminar hablar comer leer escribir todo
hasta montes hasta poder montar hoy en
una bici de paseo para mí mauricio es un
gigante historias de superación dramas
como el que nos está contando y también
en la violencia forma parte de la
historia del ciclismo en colombia por
ejemplo el asesinato por paramilitares
del padre de rigoberto urán o el
asesinato del mismo flórez o el
secuestro por las farc de lucho herrera
como influido la violencia en el
carácter de los ciclistas o en la
historia del ciclismo colombiano
es verdad que colombia pagó un tributo
muy importante
a los narcos y elegía pero sí fue fueron
sus hojas más negras de toda su historia
pero se salvó ser vivo de los carteles y
se elevó de la lejía y hoy colombia
puede estar orgullosa
haberse limpiado su mala imagen y
construido una fama completamente nueva
es parte importante gracias al ciclismo
diría que con ella dijo chávez
ribó superman dani martínez allí está la
vía ya que no está en el tubo
con esta nueva generación y todo eso los
modernos colombia alcanzó sentarse en la
cumbre del escalafón mundial del
ciclismo y estos nombres son de los más
cotizados ahora
por los más grandes equipos del sistema
mundial en el libro se puede leer que
ahora todo el mundo quiere tener a un
colombiano en el equipo
mira hasta el team dubai emirates que se
fue a buscar a los mejores
sub 23
armar su equipo que se llama team way
colombia o algo así
o sea que ahora son casi imprescindibles
para las competiciones mundiales
en el libro cita unas declaraciones del
director del tour de francia christian
prudhomme que dice bernal necesita como
federer en el tenis a un nadal quien es
para usted el nadal de bernal
diría que añadiría a la frase de gestión
problema un tercer nombre que necesita
también un djokovic para mí él djokovic
seguía hoy primos o bilic el máximo
favorito del dúo 2020 pero digamos que
él
nadal depende de cómo se la frase el
segundo rival rival y para mí el más
grande en el futuro es belga un
jovencito de casi 20 años y se llama 5 y
vinnie pool
que no está en el tour seguramente bueno
a nuestra audiencia hay un test en
colombia ya lo saben pero a lo mejor en
otros países no porque se les da el
sobrenombre de escarabajos a los
escaladores colombianos
el 1er
el primer gen lleva el apodo de
escarabajo fue ramón o dios el icónico
campeón en los 50 carlos actúo juega al
que llamaban el virus de andy el
periodismo
sería el inventor de la marca esa magia
de hoy ha pasado en la cultura en
colombia del ciclismo pero es que acá
abajo no es una una denominada una polo
de casualidad porque en colombia existen
más de 75 mil clases de escarabajos y
hasta que se jodió una película llamada
escarabajo inspirado en la vida de
patrocino jiménez y hace poco para
buscar aún como es importante
descubrieron en los llanos orientales
una nueva especie de escarabajo y los
buscados los científicos del instituto
nacional en bogotá lo llamaron
nairobi en referencia a la popularidad y
el prestigio de mayor quintana bueno
guía nos queda muy poco tiempo le
podremos leer en español pronto sí ojalá
he tenido buenos y ojalá pronto pero he
tenido la suerte de encontrar en
colombia a dos editoriales laguna
la luna que van a publicar ese libro
bernal y los hijos de la cordillera en
la aviación español
es una buena noticia porque todos los
beneficios de la venta del libro van a
ir a la fundación de esteban chávez
dedicada a los niños con problemas
ortopédicos pues muchísimas gracias
hijos le deseamos todo lo mejor con la
versión francesa y también con la
española muchas gracias y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rf y mundo.com
france24 puntocom hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]